To Children
Hello Hello Brother Jaan Subhash Chaudhary Youth
Boxing Contest Friends Welcome to the
video of the series in this video Vihar Talking about
Reinforcement Learning
Report Chapter 10 Top 10 Electronic Please
like button subscribe all videos and click on
the bell icon for new new video
Notification
so guys author try to commit Udayveer and
this word enforcement
subscribe with me and
this machine so
such a machine that
time and
subscribe to that how this machine is
detecting and if it is detected i.e. it
has from trimming dataset  So how was this computer
supervisor different from others, due
to which Bigg Boss seemed to be watching,
Supervisor Nigam saw that he
also desired input and output from cricket here, he knew
that if you see this then you will get time, but
here parents are prevented.  Here is the
Prem Director Data Sets Policy, what do we
do, we pile these up on the machine and
what do we do with the results at that time, we process that thing
and this maximum reward,
anyone keeps repeating this by tweeting
and like a bunch of maximum report.  Sir, he
does a show on Shoot Him Alive, that's
why please post an edit in it to understand it
better and let's take an example. There
is a problem in the example, that is, there is exam
time within which we will see how to
solve it. If there is a problem then it is bloody.  Comedy has
happened
200 here you can see here
in this image there is a robot there is an anklet and this is the
time you have opened the moon of the robot it
will return and its record will be there time is
standing in the middle which is fire means
its  There will be a hindrance when he goes to you, if you
take a part including one, he will note it down and will
definitely be on one step, if he passes through the hotel, he will
get a minus point, then you will punish there, so
what is the point of wearing our crown to see that Amrit Maximum and Pot  And
in which shooting and list to pass that
he should cross and win the record, then the
bachelor will cover all the steps in it, that is, he will be
sent to the hotel, he will punish
him with the machine and then we will use the second five from
where he will go and with tension.
Whatever fire is going to go away, we will get a report from there
and to
cover only one power, if we get a report,
that is Bluetooth, this has
not been formalized, like
important role, level, big, in English, it will keep
increasing,
so we have  Seen how are
not using an anonymous gift to see a dutable and foot
now see the applications of JDS
then at this time reinforcement learning which is
used and is the affection of Bigg Boss recent driving
how mother parmesan more complete
here difficult but you  Should have
different spinner killed,
modernization leads to lynching and if
any human is coming for meditation, what to
keep him there, what to do, then this is known as the
application of enforcement turning
natural language processing is
used a lot on media.  If you
look at the progress of this thing, till now there has been
any robot game in it, it is a dead game, that
mother, this will be used the most, then you will
want to learn basic knowledge, swift learning, abe, from the application, it only does
investment, learning and  How is
morning different from Rajdhani, that's all in this video.
If you liked it then like it and
signal